مع كل هذا التصعيد منعرج اخر ينتظر الحرب
الاوكرانيه فالكثير من التصريحات
والتلميحات تشير الى نوايا روسيا شن هجوم
جديد على اوكرانيا سيكون بريا هذه المره
اخر من اشاروا الى ذلك الامين العام لحلف
الناتو ينسس تلتون برج الذي قال ان هناك
دلاله تشير الى ان موسكو تستعد للهجوم
البريه على اوكرانيا وقبله كان مستشار
رئيس الاوكراني ميخائيل ببطليات قد اكد
ايضا ان روسيا تدرب جنود استعدادا لهجوم
جديد المحتمل مصدر تحدث عن الهجمه الروسيه
الجديده وهو معهد الدراسات الحرب في
واشنطن وذلك في تقرير نشره مؤخرا
السؤال المطروح الان وبعد حوالي سنه من
بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه كيف تكون
هذه العمليه البريه الجديده في حال حدوثها
حسب التقارير فان الهجوم المحتمل سيبدا من
بيلاروسيا سيما هو ان موسكو حشدت قواتها
بشكل واضح مؤخرا حشد قوه الروسيه في
بيلاروسيا يعطي فكره حول المصاري المحتمل
للعمليه البريه التي قد تنطلق من شمال
اوكرانيا وربما ستستهدف العاصمه والهدف من
استهداف الشمال الاوكراني قد يكون مجرد
تكتيك للتضليل لجذب القوات الاوكرانيه
بعيدا عن المناطق الرئيسيه نقطه الانطلاق
الثانيه المحتمله للهجوم البريه الروسي قد
تكون من شمال غربي حيث تم رصد زياده في
اعداد الجنود والاسلحه والدبابات في هذه
المنطقه خلال نهايه السنه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]